oddly you wouldn't think it we have
royal connections on the sofa because
Miranda I mean he wouldn't think it look
at us he went to school with Kate
Middleton well it she went to my school
for about two terms I believe not when I
was there
oh I see very old but yes as you can say
at my school we were bred for Queens
[Laughter]
okay what was the name you were school
dine high school for girls were all come
to Berkshire it was quite posh it was
sort of quite yes it was called quite
high achieving you go to school reunion
now and I think it's quite good that you
know I can say I'm a comedian on the
telly but that's found upon you've got
people going oh well my children
mozzarella and prosciutto quite to brood
you know work is a bit of a break even
though I'm the head of the UN they go
your comedian I been on this house sure
yeah for like three weeks and she was
very well-to-do but turned out as soon
as we got down to a bit of nookie she
was filthy so a big fan of down house
the second basin is stable just know how
the school got its name now did you go
to school with Kate Middleton no I
wasn't that down house I was at her I
wasn't allowed near down house after
work
no I went to mu bruh where she went
after that I think your private schools
yeah that I mean that's the most
ludicrous thing this Kate will didn't
even be nominated she's the first
commoner to marry into the royal family
they write about her like she's from the
ghetto right the college made Midsomer
Murders but like the wire one black guy
in the entire school who is my friend
called Daniel who the headmaster used to
use in every single school photograph
the end of the rail but I wasn't in the
first 11 cricket team where you are now
- so she was that but I wasn't there at
the same time as Cape Middleton but I
know people that went out with her and
so I knew people that went out with her
at school
I'd gone out if I'd got with the Queen
at school I've never shot a valid [__]
for the rest of my life
one of my friends open his wallet to
paper drink I'd be like yeah I've tapped
that
[Music]
you